And, uh, I, I feel like
there's a fundamental,
fundamental problem with the way
people approach ideas. And, uh,
I think it goes back to what we're talking
about earlier about right versus left
or Republican versus Democrat.
They're not thinking of the
consequences of arguing for a,
against the possibility that
climate change is a human costing.
They're not thinking of the consequences.
They just want to win. Right. Right.
And want their side to be ready
to be right. And the, you know,
what bums me out is they don't understand
the consequences of that for the both
the American enterprise and
the human enterprise. Right?
I mean, because, you know,
uh, if you, if you keep calling
one branch of science a hoax,
then what's to say the other
branches like, well, you
know, then you just, you're,
you're rolling down this slippery slope
where like the other countries, you know,
like,
so most of the,
of the Nobel Prizes Americans have
one where people from other countries,
they came here to do their science because
we had the best scientific enterprise.
The next generation, we'll
just go somewhere else. I'll
go to China. You know, so,
um, there's that part of it. And the other
point it's like, dude, it's just science.
It doesn't care about your
political views and you know,
it's not fair to use the cell phone
and take the antibiotics and then turn
around and like,
and then suddenly treat this thing as if
it was another thing in your bucket of,
you know,
ideologies.
I think also people think if you
somehow or another compromise industry's
ability to,
to work,
that you're going to kill jobs and you're
going to damage the economy and that's
more important. Yeah. But I think
it's the exact opposite. Right?
And if people really saw it,
right, I mean, um, you know,
again, just like I'm saying,
climate change shows how
powerful people become.
It also shows how powerful
are our enterprise. Right?
We did this by, you know,
building businesses by
building enterprise by,
and we built this world girdling machine
of civilization and it, you know,
the planet actually noticed.
Why do you like that term world?
Girdling because that's, it gives
me the EXEC girdle wrapping around.
It's because it's from like a Shakespeare,
like from a Caesar or something.
I always thought it was good, but it's
the idea that like, you know, in, um,
the foundation trilogy, the
Isaac Azman Off, you know,
classic science fiction
thing, then there's the city
of the planet of Transport,
which is the center of the,
uh, the empire, the collected
empire. And it's, you know,
it's basically the whole planet.
It's been covered in city, you know,
like the other,
that planet,
you got to go down like 500 levels before
you get to the surface. So that idea,
you know, I mean, what I like about
it is the idea that like, you know,
we've done something, we're kind of
covered the planet in our, our effect,
you know,
covered the planet in our enterprise.
So this issue of business is that like,
um,
there's a place I can stand in Rochester.
I did this for NPR and
there's the Erie Canal.
I can stand right on the edge of the
Erie Canal. Then there's a train tracks.
The tracks was laid,
those tracks were laid back and you know,
the original line back in
the 18th whatever seventies
then there's a highway and
then there's the airport right over there,
four different infrastructures,
you know, which he, everyone took
huge amounts of money to build,
one of which we don't even use anymore.
Right. So the idea of building an a, an a,
an infrastructure that will,
that will not be carbon polluting will
not trigger climate change. Like did it,
this is what we do.
You know.
So the idea that there's gotta be
more jobs that come out of this,
then it could ever come out
of fossil fuels. You know,
it's not a big deal for human beings
because that's what we do to switch
infrastructures and there will be a lot
of wealth generated up by, you know,
just like there was when we
switched to the trains, you know,
where's the argument coming that we owe?
Because there are people that
just adopt the, the party line,
the party line that climate's always
changed and human beings barely affected.
And it's not something to concentrate
on. Where's that coming from? Again,
I think it's the, you know, the gradual
political polo polarization of everything,
you know, cause you look at, in the,
um, we're now at the, uh, what is it,
30 year anniversary of Jim
Hanson, who was, you know,
the famous climate scientist giving his
testimony in front of Congress in 1988
on a hot, sweltering summer day. We said,
climate change is already happening,
you know,
and that made news everywhere.
And that was the first like public
awakening that this was happening.
And if you look at the first Bush
administration, they were like, oh yeah,
we're ready to do something about
this year. We can do it, you know? Um,
and then it just gradually over time,
as the whole political polarization thing
happened, you can actually see the, uh,
the, the very purposeful denial, right?
They took a page out of the cigarette
companies yeah. For years, right.
The cigarettes were like, oh, if I,
cigarette companies are like, no,
it's not a problem. So they
were purposefully, you know,
there were people had money invested,
right. You know, like didn't of,
this is a documentary that
that goes into that, um,
w what is the name of that merchants
of doubt. Merchants of doubt.
That's a great book, man.
That's a really good book. Yeah,
the documentary is really good too.
So it was purposeful,
but it's also confusing.
It's like why are they doing that?
Like who's paying them to do that?
Obviously the cigarette companies would
be paying the same people to put doubt
into the idea that cigarettes are
addictive or cigarettes cause cancer.
And this is what had
been done in the past.
Now the same people are involved in doing
it with climate change. Right. But why?
Uh, well, you know,
at one time I wrote a piece for the NPR
that was kind of positive about like,
hey, we can switch infrastructure
is like I'm saying.
And some guy wrote me back very angry and
he said, you know, the proven reserves,
you know, the stuff, the oil
that's in the ground has a wealth,
has a valve monetary
value. Like they, you know,
that's in there in the oil
companies, banks, you know, the,
in their bank accounts of one point $5
trillion. And like I said, dude, you know,
people have gone to war for a lot less
than one point $5 trillion. So you know,
if we were to really be like, hey
man, we can't burn that, you know,
you're gonna have to
leave that in the ground.
That's like through their bank
accounts going like zero pretty fast.
So what I don't, so it's those
industries. I think that's part of it.
And then it gets,
you get linked to other things and then
it becomes this sort of like mass, uh,
you know,
becomes the political poll.
They use the political
polarization to sort of, you know,
sort of make this happen.
It doesn't happen.
You look at other countries aren't
doing this right. That's the one thing,
you know, other countries, there's always
a little bit of climate denial going on,
but we're like the only country
that's guys you can see.
Cause we're the only ones who are
not part of the Paris accord. Well,
it's one of the weirdest things
about this right left things.
The left is always supporting
the environment. The,
the left is all about the environment.
The left
is about clean air and clean water. And
how did that happen? I don't understand.
I don't understand that either.
The whole thing is very strange.
Well, I got, you know, I mean,
I have issues with, you know,
environmental lists too because, um, I
think one of your shows I was watching,
you know, the whole idea of
Eco Bros, right? And you can
eco brode by people. And I,
so I have a piece in the New
York Times today, an op Ed,
where I'm basically saying like, look
man, the planet is going to be fine. Like,
you know,
long term,
there's nothing we can throw at the
biosphere that it's going to kill it.
We're in. It's not about
saving the planet, the Earth.
He's not a fuzzy little bunny.
You know,
the planet is powerful and
it's really about saving us.
Let's be honest about what's going on.
And there's gonna be all kinds of ethical
choices that go on that, you know,
the polar bears may not be able to come
along with us on the ride here. You know,
we need a healthy biosphere with, you
know, a lot of biodiversity, but you know,
we're part of it and we're
going to have an impact.
There's no such thing as no impact.
And you know,
already I'm getting ECO brode
people are like, you just, you know,
you don't care about life. Yeah. What
about I just like, oh, come on man.
I just put it in the thing I said we need
to be wise and compassionate, you know?
But they're like no
convenient opinions.
I mean this is,
this is one of the things you get
involved with when you start talking with
people about really important issues.
I mean,
it's like we were talking about
earlier, they want to be right. Yeah.
And they want to be on the
side. It's righteous and with
virtue and ethics. Right,
right. And they find anything that
you disagree, they disagree with it.
You're saying they don't ask
you questions, they don't go.
What do you think the implications are?
Like how do you,
how do we minimize the effects and the
negative consequences of are they just
immediately want to say, you are
insensitive. You are an asshole.
You are the problem.
Yeah.
You didn't know my way around that.
And that's what the whole
book is about is to like,
when you've got a
polarization, right? You know,
where you know you're
either this or you're that.
The thing that this is like a mathematical
idea is to go orthogonal. You know,
when you, when you, you know,
you go, cause you know, it's
a line basically, right?
Either on this side or that side go 90
degrees to it and now you're in a whole
new space. Now you're up and
down to the left and right.